hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
botnet Battle Royale has an ever
evolving storyline which seems quite
random at times but as each season
brings new live events we are slowly
piecing together law for the time being
I'm leaving the story of fortnight save
the world out of this equation this
one's all about battle royale story
which has been constructed from
cinematics live events and those loading
screens - you ready let's do this
the first live event which shook the
in-game world started off as a shooting
star across the skies during season 3
but as the days turned into weeks that
burning fireball in the sky looked like
more than a passing comet lookout points
and viewing platforms were constructed
around the island welcoming the meteor
we all tried and failed to predict the
day it would hit us and some even
predicted alien life to be on board that
UFO
suddenly without warning pieces of the
comet began to hit the island destroying
man-made structures influencing fights
and causing havoc everywhere
with the introduction of season four
fortnight's island was finally hit by
more than debris large portions of the
former UFO destroyed many areas of the
map with the main impact destroying
dusty depot and turning it into a barren
hole in the ground instantaneously the
government erected barriers around the
impact site hiding away the central part
of the meteor those remains glowed red
potentially indicating life inside
elsewhere around the islands the cleanup
began with government officials
transporting the fragments of the comet
some of which grunted anti-gravity
abilities momentarily to anyone who
touched them tilted towers narrowly
avoided complete annihilation but one
building wasn't so lucky
that building and all the other areas
were renovated over the following weeks
and months finally it looked like all
the fragments and hot rocks were being
transported to a mountain over by snobby
shores the mountain was revealed to be a
lair cut into the rock face hidden from
the majority of the island some say it
was created for a movie shoot others
believe this was a facade and a secret
government facility is housed inside
especially as a rocket was seen either
way everything was about to change after
the final meteor fragment over by the
crater was discovered opened and whoever
was inside left a trail of destruction
all the way to the mountain lair the
visitor was revealed but nothing is
known about his origins he quickly found
a way to power the rocket and then came
the day he chose to launch broadcasting
the signal to all the televisions in the
vicinity either warning the innocent of
preparing them for annihilation was he
here to conquer us or was he simply
trying to get back home what happened
next
only happened a single time and could
not be repeated here's how it went down
the visitor somehow managed to create
ruptures in time and rifts between
dimensions although it looked like
tilted towers was about to be destroyed
a malfunction caused the rocket to warp
around the map the rift left behind
began to eat away at the four night
world with nom noms the tomato head and
the derp burger being ripped from this
reality and vanishing overnight but then
something even stranger happened items
from other worlds began to drop through
the rifts in time a stagecoach was found
above moisty Maya a skeleton of a huge
animal or maybe a dinosaur or spotted in
moisty Maya and a huge anchor was
spotted between snobby shores and greasy
Grove which look ancient in design
perhaps Roman perhaps nas something was
definitely happening here season 5
arrived and changed the world further
once the rifts in time and space opened
the drift character was dragged onto the
island alongside the fabled der burger
bright bomber and her crew showed drift
around the island and especially the new
areas to discover midway through season
five the crack in the sky began to burn
down a group of cactuses cacti capped
cacti whichever is correct once all the
cacti were demolished the rift did this
a mysterious cube was created which
gifted shield when close enough but
would repel any damage at the closest
player to the cube so what did we all do
we all killed each other for a while
which was fun
eventually the cube began to roll around
the map and left Nordic runes in the
ground linking back to the nos team we
found in the battle paths and the theory
of Ragnarok bringing the end to the
current world over the next month the
cube went about its business including
smashing down the building until T
towers which has been under construction
since season four began epic just love
to trollers back to the loading screens
saw the arrival of the enforcers which
look like intergalactic police will have
to wait to see what happens here because
even on the last day of season 5 nothing
has been confirmed watch this space
so the cube finally made it over to loot
lake and this
[Music]
the cube melted into loot lake causing
the top layer to become a repellant kind
of trampoline gel loot lake became [ __ ]
lake doesn't have the same ring to it
one week later things changed yet again
season six began and the cube was not
finished with us yet
lifting the loot lake island into the
air
[Music]
the moment the floating island was
created the cube took it for a ride and
revisited all the room spots on the
island ripping them out of the ground
and transferring some sort of energy to
them before moving on to the next over
two weeks the cube island moved around
the map slowly expanding itself through
the house above
once the cube reached the final room
another phenomenon happened all the
surrounding rooms were ripped from the
ground and pulled towards the cube this
time the cube was feeding from all the
rooms and over the next few days the
cube reached its full capacity
the floating rooms dropped from the sky
and hit the ground and the cue island
went back to its home above loot lake
with its newfound energy the cube
projected a beam of light into the air
and fort nightmares began
the island became infested with the
undead these husks were everywhere the
loot lake island was smashed into pieces
but with his job done the cube began to
drain away the energy and power it had
built up for the season opened a gateway
to a zombie Cataclysm for five days we
battled against the husks the nightmare
was almost over and to mark the end
another live event brought chapter one
to a close the end of the cube
rest in peace Kevin here's how it went
down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that's where we are so far in the
live event story of fortnight Battle
Royale from the first sightings of a
shooting star to our brief time in
another dimension thanks for the
memories Kevin chapter one in Battle
Royale story looks to have been
concluded for now
Luke Lake has completely changed covered
in flowers butterflies and rainbows is
this the beginning of the end or the end
of the beginning let's hope the story
continues to evolve but what will happen
next can you predict the next event
please up vote the ones you like in the
comments below if you found this video
helpful please think about supporting me
and amaru in the support a creator event
for no pressure
UVU I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]